nous sommes au 42e jour de l'offensive
ars et les états unis et l'europe
envisage de contribuer aux coûts ont
toujours en frappant au portefeuille les
européens qui sont en train de finaliser
un cinquième train de sanctions dont
parle avec bruno daroux bon jean bruneau
est envisagée pour le moment je le
disais dans les titres un embargo sur le
charbon aux russes une source d'énergie
des tombes plus facile à remplacer un
immense et plus facile à remplacer mais
ça un certain nombre quand même de
conséquences alors il faut savoir
d'abord que globalement le charbon aux
russes représentent 46% du total des
approvisionnements de l'union européenne
en charbon donc ce ne serait pas neutre
ce n'est pas rien après effectivement le
charbon comparé aux livraisons de
pétrole et surtout de gaz évidemment
c'est moins important donc a priori
moins d'impact sur les économies de
l'union européenne mais attention
elizabeth si le charbon ne vient plus de
russie il faudra bien qu'il vienne de
quelque part notamment pour certains
pays plus à l'est et puis à l'allemagne
aussi qu'ils continuent à recourir à
cette énergie fossile
d'ailleurs la bulgarie envisage très
sérieusement de rouvrir ses centrales à
charbon et l'allemagne peut-être serait
contrainte de le faire aussi ceux qui la
pose un autre problème
outre un problème économique parce que
il risque d'y avoir une période où
l'approvisionnement en charbon sera un
peu défaillant l'autre problème
évidemment c'est que du coup l'union
européenne en tout cas certains membres
de l'union européenne vont plus remplir
leurs objectifs de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique qui est liée
notamment à une moindre utilisation du
charbon dont vous voyez que rien n'est
simple mais enfin c'est aujourd'hui ce
que devrait décider les européens de
stopper les livraisons de charbon russe
à l'europe ce encore une étape de plus
un seul avant dans la haine a d'ailleurs
redit ce matin il y aura d'autres
sanctions après ce cinquième paquet de
sanctions et charles michel lui a laissé
entendre clairement dit à strasbourg
tout à l'heure que tôt ou tard des
sanctions sur le pétrole et sur le gaz
russe hélas et d'autres applications qui
sont en jeu on va pas pouvoir y échapper
oui il a dit à mon nom ça va être
nécessaire mais alors on sent bien que
sur le pétrole et surtout sur le gaz
russe là on avance quand même à pas
feutrés d'où d'ailleurs l'énervement
vous avez cité du président hélène ski
qui accuse les européens d'indécision de
un peu de tourner en rond si vous voulez
de peu de procrastiner est de ne pas
agir dans ce domaine mais il faut dire
que là le sujet est d'importance parce
que à tout simplement si notamment les
livraisons de gaz russe à l'europe
s'arrête on a dit déjà plusieurs fois
sur ce plateau et bien alors certains
pays l'allemagne en tête mais il ya
aussi l'italie qui sont très dépendants
du gaz russe même des pays comme la
france qui le sont moins d'en face à
représente quand même 17% de
l'approvisionnement en gaz pour la
france bref là ça aura un impact non
seulement un impact sur les au niveau
macro économique parce que comment on
remplace le gaz alors ces états
européens c'est peut-être ça qui
explique le retard sont en train de voir
comment fournir à l'europe des
approvisionnements alternatif en
provenance des états unis de l'algérie
du qatar par exemple on sait que
notamment les négociations avec le qatar
sur l'envoi de gaz naturel liquéfié sont
très très avancé m'enfin faut quand même
que ça se concrétise tout ça demande du
temps et on sent bien que les européens
la dsit à aller jusque là en tout cas
évidemment pour les russes ce serait un
nouveau coup dur parce que c'est l'autre
question de l'ensemble de ces sanctions
quel est l'impact sur la population aux
russes est ce que des sanctions déjà
fait tomber un régime autoritaire pas
vraiment mais là ces sanctions sont
particulièrement lourdes il ya un
chiffre ce matin qui est quand même
intéressant sur un premier impact de ces
sanctions sur le public russe c'est que
les ventes de voitures neuves se sont
quand même effondré de 63 % au cours du
premier trimestre donc ça c'est un
premier indicateur mais évidemment ces
sanctions est ce qu'elle arrive à faire
chuter un régime autoritaire voire
dictatorial comme celui de vladimir
poutine et donc à faire stopper la
guerre en ukraine c'est évidemment la
grande question merci beaucoup à bruno